hello there week three of fortnite
season eight is here and with it comes a
bunch of map updates and story secrets
for us to uncover sometimes they are
huge sometimes they are small and
sometimes they involve gnomes and epic
prison breaks more on that soon so sit
your butt down for hopefully eight
minutes and let's break down everything
that has happened since we last met up
two weeks ago oh and here take this
shameless code adamaru begging please
and thank you
[Music]
we have to start at steamy stacks for
years this building stood stoically
until today steamystax has now lost its
power supply kevolution is over i have a
question right away is this our kevin
from chapter one is this the rolling
cube of death we spent time with all the
way back in 2018. steamy stacks is now a
shell of its former self the vats of
kevin juices has been destroyed and this
cube isn't stopping for anyone but soon
it will face the golden cube waiting
outside i've sat here all week and
watched this thing with other losers
from my discord the golden cube two
weeks ago was outside holly hedges and
in that time frame it has made its
journey all the way around the map to
here first moving up to sweaty sands
before awakening the purple cube there
this action though led to the purple
cube at that crash site having babies so
to quote the movie up kevin's a girl
thanks to fn assist for this replay file
by the way you should go follow him on
twitter after the awakening was over the
golden cube continued to the next kevin
up at pleasant park what is extremely
important to note now is the movement of
kevin and the kids as they roll around
the ground beneath them becomes
corrupted making a path that will likely
end at the center point of the island
the place the storm king was summoned
two years ago and sure enough the golden
cube got to the next kevin and it
happened again more babies
right now the golden cube has reached
steamy and it's only a matter of minutes
until the process is repeated but this
time it's our kevin the chapter one
kevin the cooler kevin let's check back
in two weeks to find out what hellish
demon the cubes will summon the storm
king tried and failed so who's next
[Music]
okay let's move on to some dumb stuff
small sub stories in fortnite that may
not impact the overall narrative but
they add a little bit of life to the
island we all need last time we met i
told you to keep an eye on the gnomes
outside lazy lake and the likelihood
they were planning a prison break at the
sheriff's office well today that became
a reality using the back wall the
genomes are now reunited and can escape
back into the wild the gnome army is
officially back together there's a few
good details here to prepare for the
blast inside the gnomes set up a table
to protect themselves but there's always
one member of the group who's a bit
strange if you don't know who that is
that's you and in this case it's this
guy buckethead gnome staying protected
like no other i don't think he's the
leader around here but he may be there
for morale the weirdo anyway that's one
of the groups of gnomes reunited but
another has now gone missing last update
loads of you told me i missed something
my apologies here at holy hedges were a
bunch of gnomes who've decided to leave
this place they've packed their teeny
tiny bags and they're waiting for a taxi
to take them away i chilled with them
for a while before the update and it
looks like they've gone forever they've
totally vanished this week i've had a
quick look around and i can't find them
at all so once again i'm asking you for
your help where the heck have the holly
gnomes gone to now they must have a new
home somewhere or maybe they're in a
convoy on their way if you find them
please at me on twitter i need to know
their whereabouts
okay let's go back to the serious story
based stuff after sloane double-crossed
us and stabbed us in the back during the
skyfire event she didn't run away like
agent jonesy did last season she stayed
here with an io crew and began salvaging
alien tech from the crash sites week one
saw them outside the docks before moving
westward to the metal bridge today they
have made it all the way to the broken
down io base and are more deadly than
ever as they defend the cargo they have
recovered this is most definitely
important to the story as sloan is such
a huge part of it but what could her new
plan be my guess is another weapon which
will arrive just as the hellish demons
take over the island for halloween we
may not be best friends with sloane but
we do share a desire to save the island
and her worse has led to some of the
best if she didn't double cross us we
wouldn't have rebooted kevin who by the
way still sits there doing absolutely
nothing go kev another hugely important
map update can be found near sloan right
now up on the hill the hashtag tinychair
is evolving once again it looks like
this over three seasons we've watched
this lonely chair shrink smaller than
humanly possible before returning with a
bare companion and a telescope that trio
then grew and this week they are about a
foot high still gazing into the sky next
update they should be life life-size
again and that's when we start begging
epic to make the bear huge with a
capital y huge
oversized bear on a chair anyone come on
you know you want it as halloween
reaches us you may want to know about
the spoopy areas of the map the stores
at each side of the island remain
dormant right now but each year they
tend to come alive at this time
elsewhere halloween has already arrived
the emo house by the high-fiving bros
has been updated to include a coffin
where the bed was and a ritual book
where the teddy one sat the person
living here has made some strange life
choices this season but they are not
alone down in one of the chalets by
misty you can find another coffin just
waiting to be activated when devil day
arrives let me know if you spot any more
of these it's likely the inhabitants of
the island will start adding decorations
to their homes very soon to get in the
mood for darkness
here's a weird anomaly we should talk
about this just in case something
happens during the first week many
people noticed a very different chest at
one of the i o bases it was in fact a
chest from chapter one of course we all
lost our minds and took this to mean
that chapter one's map was returning
hey it could be i guess but in week
three that chest is no more it's a
chapter two chest now here's something
you may not have noticed during week two
a piece of the road at the old swamp was
replaced with a chapter one road only a
single corner was evident and once again
this week the chapter one asset was
reverted to the chapter two island
instead
what could this mean could this be a
genuine mistake from a dev or could this
be confirmation that they are working on
a retro chapter one version of the map
with old lighting and the old art style
is it time to get hyped or is this just
wishful thinking oh by the way the hole
in the map is now fixed boo
but there's a new one down at camp cod
yay how long until epic patched this
maybe an hour i'll give it an hour a
tiny map update i wanted to reference
this week happened up where one of the
new i o outposts landed look over the
edge up here and you'll see the former
scarecrow and his buddies thrown over
the edge this was actually a returning
easter egg from chapter one which my
friends called the aaa meeting i don't
think it's really called that which saw
a circle of friends including a
scarecrow and teddy bears sitting
together having a chat well now that has
been toppled from the hillside and i
guarantee this teddy will want revenge
you mark my words just as i was
finishing this video this spot here was
noticed a new ritual site on the hill
over the farm it has three flaming pots
in a perfect triangle formation i have
no idea what this is for maybe a new npc
i don't know i just thought you should
know what is this for
[Music]
over the next fortnight of fortnite the
golden cube will continue to awaken the
remaining purple cubes who will all have
ickle tiny babies but what is their end
game it has to have something to do with
halloween could it be a cube poi or are
they summoning a demon to fight let me
know how i did this week did i miss
anything in this update please hit me up
on twitter if i miss something and i'll
add it next time thanks for staying till
the end here's a bunch of code adamaru
legends who rocked my code last week
much appreciated thank you very much i'm
adam you're awesome i'll see you next
time